c'est un animal qui divise dans les
pyrénées l'ours brun avec de nouvelles
femelle lâché qui sont aujourd'hui une
cinquantaine à protéger selon les uns à
chasser pour d'autres un débat vieux
comme la montagne
[Musique]
l'ours ennemi numéro 1 des bergers
depuis toujours pour protéger leurs
bêtes
il n'hésite pas à prendre les armes
des battues sont organisées comme le
raconte ce chasseur en 1969 est en
marche chez moi je me charge qu'il le
fit carrément et je l'attends jacques
parizeau toi j'aime beaucoup je suis
tombé raide le nombre d'ours est presque
divisé par deux entre 1954 et 1970 alors
en 72 la chasse est interdite
mais malgré tout entre 75 et 95 13 ours
sont tués il n'en reste plus que cinq
se pose alors la question de la
réintroduction des 1988 qui fait débat
chez les élus et les bergers dire en
somme l'ours en retour à nous ça veut
dire on pose aussi un problème
d'installation des jeunes bergers
on pose le problème de la continuité du
pastoralisme connaissent pas trop mais
aussi au pastoralisme la réintroduction
est lancée en 1996
et voici jiva et melba deux femelles de
slovénie de la même espèce que l'ours
pyrénéen
huit ans plus tard en 2004 neuf
individus sont répertoriés et pourtant
cannell mortes s'envolent tout espoir de
conserver une ligne et d'ours de pure
souche pyrénéenne
c'était la dernière femelle existantes
l'ourse cannelle tuée par un chasseur
pro et anti ours c# à nouveau sur la
politique à adopter et en 2010 c'est une
victoire pour les opposants pas de
réintroductions massives simplement des
remplacements quand les ours sont morts
accidentellement et on compte sur le
croit naturel
effectivement les ours se reproduise ils
sont estimés à 43 en 2010 est au dessus
du niveau de 1970 l'animal et l'homme
semble avoir trouvé le moyen de partager
la montagne le nombre de dégâts par
course est très inférieure à ce qu'il a
pu être par le passé et c'est bien la
preuve qu'on ne peut faire cohabiter un
pastoralisme vivant et moderne et la
présence d'une espèce comme l'ours dans
les pyrénées
pour autant la paix ne semble pas
d'actualité
les attaques sur les troupeaux se sont
multipliés en 2010 8 347 dossiers de
dommages d'ours enregistré depuis le
début de l'année plus du double par
rapport à 2010 est avec 155 cas recensés
sur la même période
[Musique]